buenas tardes
quiero
y transmitirles una experiencia
me permitió
aprender
algo que
me ayudó a
a cambiar
mi vida en adelante
primero quiero para esto invitarlos aquí
cierren los ojos por un momento
y que los mantengan encerrados
quiero que cada uno de ustedes
piense
qué cosas podrían hacer sin abrir los
ojos
si podrían salir de este lugar
podrían
dirigirse al metro
y retomar sus actividades habituales
y dar a sus casas oa su trabajo
abran los ojos
ahora
quiero
y decirles que este
sentimiento que pueden haber tenido de
inseguridad
o de incapacidad
de hacer las cosas cotidianas
es lo que le ocurre a una persona que
adquiera una discapacidad como la
ceguera
qué es lo que me ocurrió a mí cuando
quedé ciego
yo era
desempeñaba como técnico en una empresa
de telecomunicaciones
casado para darle familia
con cuatro hijos
y tuve que dejar mi trabajo
quedarme en la casa
y además para cada cosa que necesitaba
hacer cualquier trámite cada vez que
tenía que salir de mi casa
tenía que depender de alguien de mi
familia y sacarlo de su
labores
a ellos para qué
me acompañaron donde yo de día
a pesar de que ellos lo hacían con mucho
cariño conté con el apoyo de mi familia
quise
[Música]
tener
algo de autonomía
quise no hacerlo
como acompañantes permanentes
y me propuse acercarme a un centro de
rehabilitación
dónde
cuando llegué ahí
me iban a enseñar ahí el uso del bastón
la movilidad el sistema braile y algunas
labores
con manualidades
eso
también me permitió conocer a un grupo
de personas que al igual que yo buscaban
una rehabilitación
todo adulto
jóvenes otros no tanto
hombres y mujeres
pero en sí todos
con muchas ganas de aprender de hacer
cosas
y con
[Música]
grandes capacidades
guiada no es aprovechada
y eso me llevó a pensar ya proponerle a
los especialistas que
algunas cosas de las que yo sabía podía
enseñarle para que ellos pudieran tener
labores productivas que pudieran
generarse ingresos
y eso fue el primer intento
nos encontramos con que el centro no
tenía recursos como para tener un taller
donde se pudieran enseñar estas cosas
siempre quedó la idea de poder tener un
centro donde pudieran ellos
y hacer cosas que les permitieran
hacer una vida como cómodo una bebida
como todas las personas como una persona
común y corriente
durante también ese tiempo por cierto yo
una vez que aprendí a usar el bastón el
sistema braile y todo lo que podía
aprender en ese lugar
e intente buscar trabajo
que no era fácil en un 90
no era común que una persona con
discapacidad - una persona ciega
anduviera buscando trabajo
entonces era un tiempo donde la
discapacidad era
algo que no era común como ahora
hablar o conocerlo
y durante ese tiempo
seguí visitando el el centro cada cierto
tiempo hasta que en una ocasión
yo estaba en mi casa me llamaron porque
iban a hacer una reunión
con toda la gente del centro
no vivía cerca cuando llegue ella había
terminado en la luna
así que me dijeron cuando llegué ya
venía saliendo les pregunté que había
que habían acordado no reunión de que se
había tratado
y ahí me informaron
se había decidido
formar el taller
sin hacer que los especialistas y les
dije bueno bueno y qué y qué
quién de ustedes válida cargo dijeron o
la gente decidió que tú vas a sacar
de ahí
formamos este taller productivo taller
de servicios para la empresa y
comenzamos a trabajar
al principio éramos todos los ciegos
y
el ánimo era bastante bueno las ganas de
trabajar siempre prevalecían y también
la broma entre los ciegos aunque no
era común a alguien que dijera oye bien
es pálido
oye qué lindo el chaleco
o cuando llama a tomar la micro alguien
decía oye este no visto tarde aunque
esté oscuro
entonces son cosas que compartíamos y
eso lo mantenía siempre un buen ánimo
para seguir trabajando
y después con el tiempo nos dimos cuenta
de que los trabajos que que recibíamos
estaban limitados
porque habían otro tipo de cosas que
podíamos hacer
pero que necesitaban una revisión visual
manteniendo siempre el espíritu de que
esto era un centro para gente con
discapacidad abrimos las posibilidades a
otras discapacidades y ahí empezamos a
incorporar gente con discapacidad física
psíquica también
y así nos vemos nos mantuvimos y hasta
la actualidad
llevamos 26 años funcionando han pasado
por nuestra nuestra empresa nos quedamos
como una empresa actualmente
han pasado más de 1000 personas
y han recibido herramientas para
desarrollo
y productivo
en la actualidad incluso nos estamos
preparando para certificar nos como
empresa vez
y esto es lo que hemos hecho durante
todo este tiempo ahora quiero invitarlos
nuevamente a que cierren los ojos por
favor
vuelvan a pensar ahora
sí
es tan difícil
hacer cosas
que ustedes las capacidades que tienen
las puedan ocupar
hay muchas cosas que pueden hacer las
personas con discapacidad
pero más importante es que la comunidad
en general le brinde la oportunidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]